was nun herr scholz was nun herr
bundeskanzler
sie haben jahrelang und zielbewusst auf
diesen heutigen tag hingearbeitet trotz
schlechter umfragen für die spd und
trotz mancher auch persönlicher
enttäuschung zb beim spd parteivorsitz
ihr umfeld war immer unerschütterlich
optimistisch gab es bei ihnen dem moment
wo sie dachten dass wird nichts mehr
ich habe es immer für möglich gehalten
dass die spd die regierung dieses landes
anführt und habe immer gedacht dass dazu
ein paar voraussetzungen gegeben sein
müssen eine geschlossene partei ein
klares bekenntnis zum kandidaten und
dann natürlich eine vorstellung davon
wie es weitergehen soll in unserer
gesellschaft die wir das sicherstellen
können dass in zehn 20 30 jahren noch
gute arbeitsplätze da sind dass wir die
industrielle modernisierung hinbekommen
die uns zugleich in die lage versetzt
den klimawandel aufzuhalten und dass wir
es schaffen mehr respekt in dieser
gesellschaft zu schaffen darüber haben
wir gesprochen und daraus haben wir
jetzt den auftrag bekommen nun sind sie
es also deutscher bundeskanzler der
neunte und der vierte
sozialdemokratische und sie ziehen ja
selbst schon parallelen haben zum
beispiel auf 1969 verwiesen als willy
brandt kanzler wurde empfinden sie die
aufgabe die jetzt auf sie zukommt selbst
so groß so historisch auch beginnt jetzt
so was wie eine epoche olaf scholz ist
beginnt jedenfalls eine epoche die diese
20er jahre ausmachen die gerade beginnen
denn denen es eben um die aufgaben geht
die ich eben beschrieben habe wenn wir
das hinkriegen wollen mit der
industriellen modernisierung müssen wir
die stromerzeugung aus erneuerbaren
energiequellen aus windkraft aus
solarenergie
massiv ausbauen das ist schon etwas das
ganz ganz zentrales wir müssen die
digitalisierung voranbringen da wird
viel gemacht werden müssen und wenn wir
für mehr respekt in der gesellschaft
sorgen für ein mindestlohn für stabile
renten dann sind das auch entscheidungen
die das zusammenleben und den
zusammenhalt in unserer gesellschaft
stärker machen die überschrift über die
koalition die sie heute auch gewählt hat
im bundestag heißt fortschritt aber
schulz was bedeutet fortschritt für sie
so wie früher
technik in allen lebenslagen
wirtschaftswachstum 24 oder am liebsten
5% oder heißt fortschritt für sie auch
nachhaltiger seien sparsamer sein auch
bescheidener sein
stehen ja gerade an einer zeitenwende in
der das eine und das andere mehr oder
weniger miteinander verbunden sein kann
also technologischer fortschritt auch
ökonomischer fortschritt der es uns
möglich macht ein starkes
wirtschaftliches wachstum zu haben und
global wettbewerbsfähig zu sein und
gleichzeitig eben die aufgabe
hinzubekommen den menschengemachten
klimawandel aufzuhalten
das ist also kein gegensatz und deshalb
ist das hier auch eine ganz besondere
fortschritts koalition weil sie sich in
diesem verständnis finden kann aber
wirtschaftswachstum muss weiter seien
grenzen des wachstums bedeutet nicht
weniger oder nullwachstum es geht darum
den ressourcenverbrauch zu reduzieren
und die klima emissionen zum beispiel zu
beseitigen sodass wie klimaneutral
wirtschaften können aber das wird
natürlich trotzdem ein besseres leben
ermöglichen ein besseres als uns heute
vorstellen können auch durch den
technologie wäre das noch gar nicht
recht glauben dass das klappen kann es
ist jedenfalls eine mammut aufgabe in
dieser dreier konstellation die erste
ampel auf bundesebene
und sie müssen ja im grunde diese beiden
pole fdp und grünen auch ein bisschen
zusammen bringen beide robert habeck und
christian lindner schon gesagt sie
wollen die koalition durchaus prägen wie
soll das funktionieren wie ist ihre
rolle dabei werden sie moderator sein
oder werden sie sich jeweils auf eine
seite schlagen es geht um einen aufbruch
und dass alle drei parteien sich
fortschritt für unsere gesellschaft
vorstellen nicht komplett identisch aber
doch mit einer großen schnittmenge das
ist die grundlage dafür dass da auch was
gelingen kann das über vier jahre hinaus
reicht und wenn ich mich noch einmal
zurück erinnere an die verhandlungen die
wir über die bildung der regierung
geführt haben dann kann ich daraus nur
den schluss ziehen dass wird sogar
gelegen das ist relativ harmonisch
gewesen auch an den punkt wo es
unterschiedliche ausgangspunkt even
kavai und es gibt auch die möglichkeit
dass nach vorne hin zu guten lösungen zu
bringen und das habe ich versucht schon
während der koalitionsverhandlungen
das soll mir auch gelingen also sie ist
in der regel aber sie wollen ja auch
macher sein passt das zusammen natürlich
es geht ja was um das was wir
voranbringen wollen und ein paar punkte
haben wir schon besprochen und nicht
genannt die wollen wir auch real
umsätzen ich nehme mal so ein thema auf
dass viele bürgerinnen bürger jetzt
umtreibt den wohnungsbau 400.000 euro
pro jahr sind was ganz reales bezahlbare
wohnung auch und natürlich gilt das auch
für die vielen aufgaben die wir uns
gestellt haben in dem miteinander
unserer gesellschaft da ist ja vieles
was unser land noch ein bisschen offener
und liberaler machen könnte liegen
geblieben wegen konservativer zweifel
und bedenken das kann jetzt zu einem
guten ergebnis nach vorne geführt werden
die konservativen zwei verfechter ist
noch kurz fragen darf die bringt jetzt
die fdp wird das klappen zwischen grünen
und fdp
das wird klappen das wird auch klappen
zwischen allen drei parteien und ich
glaube dass es nicht richtig wäre zu
sagen da sind zwei die sich streiten und
dann so auch die spd dafür dass es einen
konsens gibt sondern es geht ja darum
dass in der sache gut aufzulösen und wir
haben ja auch unsere eigenen
vorstellungen davon was zu tun ist und
noch mal wenn man sich an die atmosphäre
der verhandlungen zurück erinnert auch
das gefühl dass heute alle hatten als
sie ihre ernennung als minister und
ministern vom bundespräsidenten bekommen
haben dann ist das schon etwas wo die
vertrauensbasis existiert die für so was
notwendig ist und vertrauen geht es auch
noch stolz wenn sie ihre erste
auslandsreise machen nach paris am
freitag sie werden präsident marktreife
und er steht von der schwierigen
wiederwahl und er hat ein bisschen
skepsis gegenüber der neuen deutschen
regierung oder vor allem gegenüber dem
neuen deutschen finanzminister christian
lindner wird er mit einer restriktiven
finanzpolitik die rolle als zuchtmeister
europas fortsetzen oder werden sie sagen
dass übernehme ich
die künftige regierung hat sich
verständigt wie wir die großen
herausforderungen die für europa stehen
lösen wollen und dazu gehört dass wir
natürlich unsere verantwortung für den
erfolg des ganzen europas anerkennen wie
wir das mit dem wiederaufbau programm
bereits gemacht haben als deutsche
regierung in europa und darüber hinaus
noch mit noch mehr gemeinsam schulden
oder jedenfalls der möglichkeit sie zu
machen es geht doch jetzt erstmal darum
dieses programm umzusetzen da sind ja
noch fast keine mittel ausgegeben und
das ist eines für viele viele jahre was
wir brauchen ist ausreichende
flexibilität wie sie sich im rahmen des
stabilitäts und wachstumspaktes in
europa ja auch jetzt als möglich
erwiesen hat wie sie haben eine ganze
krise bekämpft mit diesem rahmen warum
soll nicht auch für die zukunft reicht
sie haben darauf hingewiesen
klimaneutrale wirtschaft schreiben sie
sich auf die fahnen während damit ja
auch ein vorbild in europa jetzt haben
sie dann die sense mit makro der
zeichnet sich jedenfalls ab denn der
hält ja für diesen umbau atomkraft als
sozusagen grüne energiequelle für
notwendig angela merkel hat dem immer
entschieden widersprochen werden sie das
auch tun wir gehen unseren weg und ich
glaube dass das auch einer es für den
wir gute gründe haben dass andere länder
die frage wie sie den menschengemachten
klimawandel aufhalten wollen anders
beantworten werden wir ja nicht
aufhalten können wir können nur
das beitragen was wir in deutschland zu
leisten vermögen und so ingenieurinnen
und ingenieure unser unternehmen unsere
wissenschaft und wir glauben dass wir es
hinbekommen können mit einem massiven
ausbau der produktion von strom aus
erneuerbaren energien nicht nur umso
stromverbräuche anders zu organisieren
sondern auch industrielle prozesse neu
aufzustellen so dass das klimaneutral
möglich ist und das wird dann natürlich
wenn das funktioniert und wenn die
globale wettbewerbsfähigkeit deutschland
darüber bewiesen ist von vielen
nachgemacht werden aber immer krank
könnte ihnen hier am freitag aussagen
solange die deutsche energieversorgung
nicht komplett grün geworden ist und
nachhaltig werde dir weiter und so eine
art ob strom importieren erstmal wollen
wir die energieerzeugung in deutschland
aus das ist doch auch einer der
fortschritte die schon mit der
regierungsbildung verbunden jahrelang
ist bestritten worden von weiten teilen
der politik dass wir einen höheren
strombedarf haben obwohl die ganze
chemie-industrie uns mitgeteilt hatten
sie braucht 2040 50 ungefähr so viel
strom wie deutschland insgesamt heute
das gleiche ähnliches kann man für die
stahlindustrie für den maschinenbau für
die automobilen sein erster punkt sein
hat bundeskanzler wo deutschland diese
importe von atomstrom aus anderen
ländern nicht mehr braucht wir haben
jetzt die grundlagen dafür gelegt dass
wir die erzeugung ausbauen können und zb
werden sie erfinden dass wir jahrelange
streitereien beenden werden über die
beschleunigung von planungsverfahren
über schnelle genehmigung wie wir das
hinkriegen dass so was auch gelingt da
soll deutschland wirklich einen
richtigen aufbruch hinkriegen und dann
wird der fortschritt möglich bleibt ein
wagnis aber eines bei dem ganz viele
bürgern und bürger mitgehen werden weil
sie sagen es geht auch für mich in
meinem ganz persönlichen leben mit
meinem beruf unmittelbar gut aus wo die
vermutlich nicht gehen mit gehen werden
ist in der lausitz kohleausstieg 2038
war vereinbart er soll wie es im
koalitionsvertrag heißt idealerweise
vorgezogen werden vielleicht schon 20 30
und dort wirft man ihn wortbruch vor sie
hätten vor ort cottbus in der region das
versprechen gegeben und nun könnte man
sich nicht auf sie verlassen oder
wiederholen sie das versprechen 20 38
darauf kann man sich in der lausitz
verlassen wir bleiben in dem rahmen den
wir in den letzten jahren
festgelegt haben und dazu gehört
natürlich die ganze zeit der massive
ausbau der erneuerbaren energiequellen
als produktions möglichkeit für strom
als voraussetzung dafür dass wir auch
zügiger aus der kohleverstromung
aussteigen können als das bisher geplant
ist diese aufgabe jetzt anzupacken das
ist die zentrale herausforderung vor der
wir unmittelbar stehen und da glaube ich
gehen viele mit weil wir ja auch ein
ganz konkretes und planen für die
zukunft derjenigen regionen in
deutschland damit verbinden der die
bisher für die stromversorgung in
deutschland so eine wichtige rolle
gespielt haben neue kraftwerke übrigens
auch neue gaskraftwerke in diesen
regionen langfristig die nutzung von
wasserstoff die nutzung all der
erzeugungs infrastrukturen die damit
verbunden sind auch neue arbeitsplätze
hat sie das wird überall passiert
versprechen lautet jetzt wir werden euch
nicht überfordern menschen und kommunen
aber ohne jahreszahl das was wir doch
die ganze zeit
hinkriegen müssen ist das nicht mehr
abstrakt gesprochen wird sondern konkret
gehandelt wird und die konkrete handlung
ist im nächsten jahr schon die
beschleunigung an der genehmigungs und
planungsverfahren die erhöhung der
ausbauziele schon bis 2030 da haben wir
schon viele leute öffentlich zugegeben
dass die bisherigen planungen nicht
gestimmt haben ich habe darüber jahre
lang geredet und jetzt sorgen wir dafür
dass wir mehr stromerzeugung in
deutschland gekommen sie sagen viele
gehen mit sie versuchen die bürger
mitzunehmen und die bürgerinnen für
scholz aber sie wissen auch dass die
glaubwürdigkeit der politik in den
letzten monaten sehr gelitten hat nicht
nur bei dem thema energie lausitz
sondern auch beim thema corona und
impfpflicht gerade im osten baut sich da
was auf und das spüren sie wie sehr
belastet es den start ihrer regierung
dass sie das versprechen es wird keine
impfpflicht geben einkassieren müssen
viele sagen ja das beginnt jetzt alles
mit einem wortbruch
die meisten bürgern bürger sind sehr
besorgt über die möglichen folgen der
korona pandemie für ihre gesundheit die
allermeisten bürgern bürger haben sich
impfen lassen und wir wissen dass das
gegenwärtige infektionsgeschehen voran
daher rührt dass es zwar sehr viele gibt
die sich impfen lassen haben aber auch
im internationalen vergleich nicht genug
wären wir weiter vorangekommen würden
wir heute nicht sorge haben müssen dass
es probleme geben könnte im hinblick auf
die kapazitäten der intensivstation
unserer krankenhäuser und deshalb ist es
doch nur richtig zu sagen wir sind nicht
so weit gekommen wie wir gehofft haben
im hinblick auf die überzeugung
ausreichend vieler bürgerinnen und
bürger von der impfung und da muss dann
ein neuer schub rein und das verbindet
sich mit der großen im kampf die wir
jetzt auf den weg gebracht haben damit
dass jetzt ein krisenstab im kanzleramt
eingerichtet dass general breuer den
leitet und das jetzt millionenfach noch
bis weihnachten noch dieses jahr
zustande zu kriegen und gleichzeitig
dann natürlich den debatte wie kriegen
wir noch mehr überzeugt und noch mehr
dazu gebracht dass sie sich auch impfen
lassen weil das für uns alle und unser
aller gesundheit wichtig und haben sich
schon zurückgewiesen den vorwurf dass
sie während der koalitionsverhandlungen
im grunde die brisanz der lage zu spät
erkannt haben vielleicht sich auch zu
sehr konzentriert haben auf klimaschutz
und andere dinge dass weisen sie ja
zurück aber im rückblick mal gesehen
bedauern sie im grunde dass sie nicht
später nicht früher angesprungen sind
dass sie vielleicht auch eben dieses
versprechen es soll keine impfpflicht
geben ausgesprochen haben aus meiner
sicht sind jetzt viele viele sehr weit
reichende maßnahmen ergriffen worden die
wir zum beispiel vor einem jahr gar
nicht ergreifen konnten also wenn wir
jetzt darüber reden dass es für den
zutritt zu restaurants zu
handelsgeschäften zu kulturellen
veranstaltungen zu kinos die
voraussetzung ist dass man geimpft ist
ein ausreichender impfschutz hat oder
aber von einer infektion genesen ist
wenn wir mental noch zusätzlich die
voraussetzung schaffen dass man sich
auch noch tagesaktuell hat testen lassen
dann sind das ja handlungsmöglichkeiten
die hatten wir vor einem jahr nicht wir
haben zusätzlich dafür gesorgt dass es
so ist dass im öffentlichen verkehr auch
eine solche regelung gilt dass man da
geimpft genese und getestet rhein kann
wir haben das für die arbeitsplätze
gemacht wir haben jetzt entscheidung
getroffen im hinblick auf das impfen von
beschäftigt 19 zoll eine richtung wo
besonders viele gruppen sind also
altenpflege einrichtungen und
krankenhäuser und aus meiner sicht ist
das schon ziemlich massiv was jetzt auf
den weg gebracht worden ist ich bin sehr
froh dass es auch gelungen ist eine
verständigung mit den 16 ländern
herbeizuführen und wie gesagt dass wir
diesen krisenstab trotzdem ist heute der
tag herr scholz mit den meisten corona
toten seit februar wie viel davon auf
die kappe der politik die nach dem
wahlkampf in der phase oktober/november
vielleicht schon september zu
unentschlossen gehandelt hat ich bin
überzeugt dass wir vor allem eine große
entschlossenheit brauchen jetzt das mit
dem impfen hinzukriegen und das will ich
noch mal sagen das ist ja etwas was wir
als bürgerinnen und bürger nur gemeinsam
zustande kriegen auch sie und die medien
genauso wie diejenigen der politik
verantwortung haben müssen darüber nicht
nur achselzuckend reden so als
beobachten oder beobachtet und wir
sollten uns als bürgern und bürger auch
ganz aktiv daran beteiligen zu sagen
leute gebt euch eindruck es ist für euch
selber für eure liebsten und für die
gesamte gesellschaft wichtig und deshalb
nutze ich jede gelegenheit das zu sagen
lasst euch impfen besorgt durch eine
blues der impfung sie sind der
bundeskanzler aller deutschen sind sie
auch der bundeskanzler der impfgegner
auch der die auf die straße gehen mit
protest wenn i tend klar ich bin
bundeskanzler aller deutschen so
verstehe ich mich und dazu gehört aber
auch dass ich klar bin in dem was ich
richtig finde und das sage glaube das
steht dann auch allen deutschen zu dass
ich in so einer existenziellen frage
nicht
schwierig bleibe sondern sage wirklich
es geht darum dass sich alle impfen
lassen und die diskussion müsse geführt
werden ich will ja auch vor allem
zuallererst überzeugen und ich finde
auch dass man keinen falschen eindruck
erweckten darf wenn die allermeisten
bürgerinnen und bürger geimpft sind
viele sich jetzt booster impfung holen
wenn viele die gar nicht gegen das
impfen sind sondern nur nicht dazu
gekommen sind das jetzt machen weil alle
merken da ist was los dann kann man ja
nicht von einer gespaltenen gesellschaft
reden wie das einige tun aber man muss
trotzdem diese kontroversen debatten
auch führen und sagen warum wir das
anders sehen und musste ich begründen
und dazu bin ich gern dass sie versuchen
jetzt zu motivieren und mit zunehmender
scholz aber gleichzeitig ist in sachsen
etwas groß mit den protesten vor den
wohnhäusern der politiker sie haben das
schon scharf verurteilt aber die frage
ist können sie etwas gegen die plattform
tun die den impfgegnern dazu dient sich
zu verabreden zu kommunizieren telegramm
kann ihre neue innenminister an dieser
stelle wirkungsvoll das instrument den
impfgegnern
impfgegnern aus der hand schlagen das am
ende dazu dient eben auch gewalt in
unserer gesellschaft zu bringen wir
haben wir bereits gesetze auf den weg
gebracht gegen hass und hetze im netz
das wird auch für die zukunft wichtig
bleiben und eine aufgabe an der man
arbeiten muss ich will ausdrücklich
sagen es geht darum dass man hass und
hetze bekämpft
akzeptable muss sein dass bürgerinnen
und bürger unterschiedliche meinungen
haben die sie auch entschieden vortragen
aber es geht ja darum dass wir
verhindern dass eine aggression
produziert wird die sich dann auch gegen
sachen oder personen richtet und ich
will das hier nochmal aufgreifen was sie
angesprochen haben fackel umzüge vor dem
privat wohnhaus eine
gesundheitsministerin sind wirklich eine
dramatische grenzüberschreitung da
müssen wir als demokraten demokraten
sagen wir lassen solche
einschüchterungsversuche nicht zu
herr bundeskanzler zu unserer sendung
gehört die satz ergänzung sie kennen das
wir geben ein halbsatz vor und sie
ergänzen ihnen möglichst kurz der erste
halbsatz lautet dass mir heute
mindestens 15 stimmen aus der
ampelkoalition gefehlt haben
es ist ein fakt ich bin mit satter
mehrheit gewählt worden und es sind auch
im übrigen wahlen unter corona
bedingungen da sind ja auch viele kranke
für meine kanzlerschaft hat mir angela
merkel mit auf den weg gegeben
glückwünsche und
dass sie weiter so vertrauensvoll mit
mir zusammenarbeitet wie wir das in den
letzten jahren aber auch gerade in den
letzten wochen seit der bundestagswahl
getan haben und wir werden uns auch
weiter austauschen auch über politik
meinen schärfsten kritiker kevin kühnert
zum spd-generalsekretär zu machen der
ist ja gar kein kritiker sondern der
künftige generalsekretär der spd jetzt
kein jetzt kein kritiker mit dass wir
bis weihnachten wirklich 30 millionen
booster impfungen schaffen es sind nur
16 tagen es ist eine ganz ehrgeizige
aufgabe aber überall im land sehe ich
neue impfzentren entstehen viele die
sich mühe geben und wir versuchen wir
auch all die probleme die offenkundig
geworden sind der logistik in der
versorgung in der beschaffung
aufzulösen und uns da hinterher zu
begeben
hoffentlich werden wir keine
unüberwindbaren hürden entdecken aber am
ende sie haben uns erst mal dran gemacht
auch wirklich ins detail zu gehen und
deshalb das sollte schon unser ehrgeiz
sein dass milch alter affären stichwort
wirecard auch als kanzler noch verfolgen
glaube ich nicht es wird überall
gesprochen was man so getan hat in
meinem langen politischen leben in dem
fall ist es ja auch klargestellt worden
dass hier sehr entschieden gehandelt
worden ist das recht neu zu organisieren
und ich bin sehr stolz auf das was wir
da unternommen haben dass kein deutscher
regierungsvertreter zu den olympischen
spielen nach china fahren sollte
ist eine debatte die jetzt ganz
aufgeregt begonnen hat ich finde man
muss sich sorgfältig beraten was
passiert es geht bei dem sport um eine
großartige sache die ja seit olympia
historischen und antiken traditionen
eigentlich zum miteinander miteinander
streitet das ändert ja bis 1936 und dem
bettler in deutschland veranstaltet hat
ja aber es ist auch erstmal so dass wir
diesen gedanken geht es nicht beiseite
packen sollten der mit olympia verbunden
ist und was das konkret bedeutet das
wird man im rahmen und internationalen
verbunden mit anderen besprechen müssen
ich jedenfalls finde dass es keinen
anlass gibt hier vorschnell sich auf
irgendeinen vorgehen hin zu dürfen
vorschnell die usa haben sich bereits
entschieden australien schließt sich an
sie werden jetzt nicht der erste der
einen diplomatischen weg hat an glaube
dass es trotzdem richtig sorgfältig zu
überlegen was man tut in der politik
auch in der internationalen politik ist
nationales handeln ganz ganz
entscheidend für frieden und sicherheit
das klingt jetzt ein bisschen so herr
scholz als würden sie weiter vor allem
der kanzler der exportnation sein die
die wirtschaftsbeziehungen mit china
nicht aufs spiel setzen will und weniger
der humanitäre außenpolitik macht wie
ihre außenministerin wenn das ein
gegensatz wäre was sie da beschreiben
dann wäre das ein interessantes thema
ist es aber glaube ich nur wenn man das
so fragt es bleibt in der realität gar
kein thema das wirklich weiter führt
sind ich ihnen auch sehr konkret sagen
was haben
männer wie willy brandt und helmut
schmidt auf den weg gebracht als sie die
ostpolitik und die entspannungs politik
entwickelt haben dass es möglich ist ein
miteinander zu entwickeln in einer
dramatisch verfeindeten situation die
auch für den frieden und die sicherheit
sehr bedrohlich wahr heute wissen wir
dass der eiserne vorhang verschwunden
ist dass die demokratie empfehlen der
kommunistischen diktaturen in europa
heute die realität ausmacht dass wir in
der europäischen union verbunden sind
miteinander hat also gewirkt und was
mussten dafür dinge verstanden werden
und trotzdem waren jan brandt und
schmidt nicht leute die nur an
wirtschaftlichen fragen interessiert
waren sie haben damit einen großen
beitrag geleistet und gemeinsam
sicherheit zu organisieren in einer welt
die ganz anders sein wird schon in zehn
20 30 jahren als heute das ist die große
aufgabe da wird es zehn milliarden
bürgern und bürger auf der welt geben da
wird es nicht nur russland und die usa
sondern auch china und korea und japan
und vietnam und indonesien und malaysia
und indien und sicher auch nationen aus
afrika und dem süden amerikas geben die
bedeutung haben für uns muss die
konsequenz sein selber stark zu sein für
uns muss die konsequenz sein verbunden
sein mit denjenigen die mit uns teilen
dass wir demokratien und rechtsstaaten
sind wie die usa zum beispiel und für
uns muss die konsequenz sein dass wir
unsere meinung und unsere haltung dieser
frage sehr klar vertreten aber auch
wissen dass ein miteinander in der welt
stattfinden muss auch mit regierung die
ganz anders sind als unsere was heißt
dass dieses starke plädoyer
herr bundeskanzler für das verhältnis zu
russland also ein land das truppen an
der grenze zur ukraine aufmarschieren
lässt sehen sie denn jetzt wenn man
ihnen so folgt den ausführungen chancen
zu einem neustart im verhältnis zu
russland
was hilft gegen putins aggressiven kurs
am ende dann doch nur härte es muss
klarheit existieren über das was für uns
außer frage steht und außer frage steht
der große fortschritt der verständigung
die seit den 70er jahren in europa
gelungen sind nämlich dass wir
gemeinsame sicherheit nur erreichen und
erhalten können wenn die grenzen und
verletzlich bleiben wenn niemand in
geschichtsbüchern wälzt wie diesmal vor
200 300 und 400 jahren war sondern sagt
die grenzen die wir heute haben werden
nicht in frage gestellt das ist die
grundlage der sicherheit die es dann
auch möglich macht ganz unterschiedliche
wege national zu gehen die aber trotzdem
nicht für die anderen jeweils bedrohlich
sah man daraus schliessen hat scholz
wenn putin noch einmal die grenzen
verletzt und er hat das ja schon einmal
getan im stichwort ukraine und es
wirklich eine invasion gibt in diesem
land worauf er sich vorbereitet offenbar
im januar dann werden sie die
gaspipeline nord stream zwei nicht in
gang setzen das wäre eine ganze
dramatische regelverletzung die noch
ganz andere konsequenzen haben würde
aber jetzt ist doch unsere aufgabe erst
mal ganz klar zu beschreiben was wir
jetzt wollen und erreichen müssen
nämlich das genau so etwas nicht
passiert schon die
widerrechtliche inversion in der krim
oder auf der krim hat ja weit über die
krim hinaus
sorgen bei allen produziert ob das jetzt
immer so geht oder nicht und das ist der
punkt warum wir so sehr auf der
herrschaft des rechts und der
unverletzlichkeit der grenzen bestehen
müssen von wem wollen sie sich da eher
rat von angela merkel in sachen russland
oder von gerd schröder
ich habe jetzt das amt nicht mit vielen
zu beraten das werde ich sicher auch
immer tun aber welche politik verfolge
das kann ja jeder genau nachvollziehen
wir haben das gerade in diesem gespräch
entwickelt
jetzt geht es also los herr
bundeskanzler
sie wollen das haben sie auch schon
gesagt in vier jahren wiedergewählt
werden ab jetzt zählt es ja wenn sie es
in einem satz sagen müssen wie würden
sie diesen anspruch an sich selbst jetzt
formulieren
klare kurs verfolgende ziele das ist
jetzt nicht nur literatur was wir da
produziert haben mit dem
koalitionsvertrag das muss alles schnell
gemacht werden insbesondere die
beschleunigung unserer fans genehmes
prozesse mithilfe rankommen in diesem
land gute kooperation unter den partnern
ich wünsche mir dass alle auch trotz
allen politischen unterschieden die
parteien familien nun mal mit sich
bringen als partnerinnen und partner
zusammenarbeiten und dass man sich
wechselseitig stark macht und ich glaube
an solchen stil der durchaus was neues
in deutschland wäre den können wir
gemeinsam prägen und dann können wir
auch gemeinsam zur nächsten wahl antrieb
daran werden sie ab heute gemessen das
war was nun übrigens nach zweig plus
regeln das muss man auch noch mal sagen
vielen dank der bundeskanzler vielen
dank liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer
für ihr interesse bis aus berlin
[Musik]